all right next up we got nick in
evansville indiana
nick what's on your mind buddy nick
callie dude
chris how are we doing uh focused about
finish my friend
hey uh just just before we get going
you're nick right
i am nick all right good nick you guys
are uh our christmas
there you go buddy what's on your mind
all right so uh
i've got a uh i've got a confusing
family
kind of question here um okay yeah
it's it's okay so i gotta give you a
little bit of back story okay
um i'm 36 my wife is 41.
my wife is adopted um and
and grew up in texas um she found her
biological mother up here in indiana
about 15 years ago
she got divorced in texas and
moved up to indiana and stayed with her
biological mother about 13 years ago
about a year after that her mother and
her grandparents
moved to china they started a
an english teaching school there um her
grandparents have been doing missionary
work
in and out of china for the past 25
years or so so they were familiar with
the uh
um all right and then
my wife and i got married 10 years ago
and as a wedding present
my mother-in-law and my wife's
grandparents
gave us a house gave us their old house
here um
free and clear and they have
lived in china ever since uh
again doing the english speaking school
there english teaching school okay
um so now because of this whole pandemic
thing
they are unable to restart their school
this year
and without an income they have now
moved back to the united states
they don't have any place to live um
they are right now talking about uh
purchasing an rv um which they
they are not uh they are not on the dave
ramsey plan so they're
they're talking about you know
potentially buying a motor home for
thirty thousand dollars and financing it
and then just driving around the u.s um
her grandparents are 85
respectively and and what not
her grandpa has kind of dropped some
hints about
how much he paid for the house uh you
know and things like that
uh uh-oh here we go yeah so i'm i'm kind
of
uh unsure that they don't really have a
very good financial situation going on
and
um i don't know what to do here
she said that we were on baby step 7 for
a while we just found you guys about a
year and a half ago
and you know we paid off we paid off our
debt and we are debt-free
we got our emergency fund in place
how much this house that they gave you
how much is it worth
about 120 000 so they gifted you this
home free and clear you never had a
mortgage
that's correct okay uh dr d what are you
going to do here man
nick here's the deal you got to decide
who you want to be
and what you want to deal with and what
relationships are or or not worth
to you and this is a boundaries question
and this is
a character integrity question and
really a
family values question between you and
your wife and if you
that your parents her parents have no
claim to the house they've got no
financial ties to the house it is what
it is what it is they can't come back a
decade later and say hey by the way we
want that house back
the other side of that is they gave you
a free house a decade ago you're a
millionaire now
and you're looking at in-laws being
homeless and so
you and your wife gonna have to decide
to sit down and say are we gonna be
participating in this are we going to
help in this are they going to be in an
rv
um but again this you're talking about a
decade
[Music]
the gift part is over as far as i'm
concerned they gave you a house 10 years
ago
it that is over what you're dealing with
now is
in in-laws that are back in the states
that may be homeless or maybe moving
into an rv
right so nick are we talking about the
mom
and dad are we talking about mom dad and
the grandparents
no uh just mother and then uh
and then grandpa and grandma so nick
what do you want to do man
well i've got three options the way i
figure it all right listen
if you're just tuning in this is not the
jerry springer show this is still dave
ramsey show so keep going nick
all right nick options uh my options are
give the house back uh option two would
be to
sell the house and give them the cash
for that
or we keep the house and
um i mean there's got to be some there's
got to be some compensation somewhere
um you know it's how i feel you know
about this but
you know as as far as what that is i
mean we've done a lot of improvements on
the house you know between
in the last 10 years we've lived here
yeah there's a fourth option nick where
they were running a business the
business went away which has happened to
millions and millions and millions of
people
right and then they had to move which
has happened to a number of people and
now they have to start on their job
and they've got to get an apartment
they've got to start over like other
folks if you guys want to as
in-laws help great that's right that's
remarkable
yeah but this idea of give it back i
mean if you guys want to give your house
away
more power to you rock on but don't feel
like you're obligated to
give a house away no i wouldn't and i
even see nick you know
the option of selling it and all that
stuff i literally i would not put that
on the table
the mindset of allowing them to come how
big is this home
uh it's a uh it's an older home it's
built in the 50s
um it is a about a 2 000 square foot
house okay and
it's you your wife and do you all have
kids uh
we do um we've got a um one child lives
in texas
um with uh with his biological father um
he's uh he's about to turn 18.
okay uh the other the other child i mean
he's 21. right he just he actually moves
back from texas and is staying with us
while he gets them to speak let me ask
you this where are they living right now
um oh uh her her mother
yeah they are actually staying in a
a friend's second house okay yeah
so they have a place okay so you know i
think it's important you and your wife
get on the same page with this
uh this could really get sideways yeah
and i think the two of you being on the
same page i wouldn't sell the house
i'm just not being able to help them and
i was going to say if they didn't have a
place to live to come
stay there for x period of time as long
as we have understanding
but i don't there's not a reason for you
to take a step back because they gave
you a gift
you know like if you gave me a tv nick
and five years later my tv
it gets broke right i'm not expecting
you to give me another one
right and so it's just this is a matter
of you getting really stable about what
you feel and where you are
but you and your wife getting on the
same page and what can you do to help
uh if they start bringing it up and all
that i'm not participating in that right
that's
there's a lot of anxiety in this
situation with a failed business and
trying to find a place to live
uh but there's no sense in nick trying
to put this all on him and if they do
start bringing it up you know asking
questions about
like hey well remember that time we give
you a house
then i think it's fair to take your
mother-in-law
out and say i realize y'all are stuck
how can we help
right what are you what do you guys need
over the next couple of months and then
if it fits in your financial plan if it
fits in your character and values and it
fits in
you and your wife's plan for your life
and for your family's life
then you can write them a check you can
help out you can let him live with you
for six months
if you want to give him the house back
because you guys have another house then
rock on to the break of dawn i just i
don't want you to do this out of
will you give us a house once and now we
owe you a house yeah you can't live like
that no you can't and what did you say a
gift with strings is manipulating
manipulation man
yeah so when they come back like
remember that time i i paid for
lunch at you know wendy's i think
you know what i mean don't remember it
got bad memory hashtag amnesia
uh man that stinks get with your wife
and get with get a plan for how you're
gonna support him and be
be helpful um but you don't owe him a
house yeah
no i completely agree be on the same
page be on the same team my friend